Selena Gomez is reflecting on the past
year and basking in the glow ain't just
feel really blessed to have this
opportunity this singer recently spoke
with InStyle magazine where she opened
up about her plans for the future and
looked back on her transformative AF
2019
she told the mag quote this year was
really really powerful for me I can say
that I'm so proud of how hard I worked
honestly I'm I'm very honored I really
am
yes girl she also dished on her holiday
plans saying she's excited to just sit
back with my family and enjoy and turn
off everything adding I always just
think about what happened and where I
want to go in life and hope for the best
well it's safe to say selena has made
the most of this year especially in the
last three months
she dropped back-to-back hit tunes with
a loose you to love me I needed to lose
you too
and look at her now both of which she
released in October but if all that
weren't enough to have Selena feeling
hella good about her year she also
performed the hits at the 2019 American
Music Awards marking her first live TV
performance in two years
[Applause]
all of this of course is leading up to
Selena's upcoming album sg2 which is set
to drop on January 10th Selena dished on
the new album
teasing quote I can say this and it
might not sound right but I've tried my
hardest to make this the best album I've
ever done and I feel like I lived up to
the expectations hopefully that doesn't
come back to bite me in the ass I'm
getting to do things that I'm passionate
about with the people that I love
something tells me that this new album
is going to be fire and I feel like I
should also note here that we might just
be getting some fire new music inspired
by Selena - her ex The Weeknd recently
registered the song title like Selena oh
damn
just a little refresher a Selena and The
Weeknd dated in 2017 for ten months
before they split in October that same
year on Monday the singer teased that he
would be dropping new music posting this
pic to his insta with the caption the
fall starts tomorrow night
then he dropped his new single heartless
late Tuesday night
oh man guys I don't know that I love
anything more than a good song inspired
by a past love and something tells me
it's gonna be a Bop of course you can
count on et to bring you all the latest
Selena news so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens see you soon
[Music]